all right here we go
now we are getting into the money feel
that we're getting closer to the sun
the more money you have the closer you
get to god don't ever forget that
oh jesus christ
[Music]
what is that [ __ ] noise
looks like there's a little baby ghost
playing the piano
there's sears one of the few sears left
i used to love going to sears when i was
a kid right they had everything from
any tool you wanted to those huffy
bicycles
they look like motorcycles and they
weighed about 80 pounds
a bunch of palm trees over there not
indigenous to california
[Music]
look at how hard all those white males
work to get those palm trees here way
back in the day on wooden ships
you know what are some of your favorite
los angeles uh neighborhoods
um venice i always think of like you
know
jim morrison and all of those guys
that's sort of like you got to have a
bit of a rock star vibe
or sort of a groupie vibe to live in
venice that's how it used to be so i was
never like that
i kind of like the belly of the beast i
like living right in hollywood
i'm not ashamed that i'm pursuing fame
i live out in a village it's just way
more real
live next to a plumber that's that's the
one
134 east okay this week i'll never get
used to that like to me
i always go by the ocean and to me the
ocean is east
but it's actually west all right it's
actually south in l.a if you're looking
at if you're at venice you're looking
south oh andrew
oh andrew someday you're going to make
somebody a happy spouse
it's actually south if you uh look at a
map and see the trajectory of the
longitudinal attitude thank you
andrew themalis
jesus christ look at that little [ __ ]
cloud sitting there little puffy cloud
there huh
no other clouds around it all lonely
that let you know that there's a lifting
force there
and you would not be underneath it
because it could possibly be a little
turbulent
we got to do one of these one time in
the helicopter
[Laughter]
an audio nightmare but a visual dream
all right these walls here for noise
abatement they're from a uh
applebee's that they knock down out in
the midwest
sometime around when oprah said beef is
bad for you
look at this [ __ ] nazi up here
there's a weird thing with that
schultz that's a german name right
[Music]
right sergeant schultz there you go i
like that guy you go [ __ ] you man all
right we had a we had bad eight years
we killed some people but uh now we're
back
so down here they got a ralph's i like
rouse ralph's is is uh you know
it's not super [ __ ] rich that guy
just cutting right in front of her he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
it's not a super [ __ ] richie place
but they got all they got you know name
brand stuff
because if i could do like the college
rankings it's probably gelson's
formerly mayfair market then it goes
ralph's
and vaughn's and john's they're like
interchangeable you know what i mean
they're like teams that andy reed
coaches they're getting to the afc
championship but they're not they're not
gonna win it you know
i'm trying to get up the hill where the
wealth is all right here we go
this is it we got a glass backboard
that says money right there somebody's
got a anybody can have a
wooden backboard you get the glass one
that's that's a big deal
you go up here this is where like you
know people have daughters and they name
them like
brooke natasha
look at this see this is like one of
these tom hanks movie beginning of a
movie street you know before he gets
trapped on an island after his space
ship [ __ ] crashes they got the
british flag there look at that
i like that they put it underneath the
american flag you know that's how you do
it
who's feeding you right now america
look at this [ __ ] pack rat there's
always one of these people with all this
[ __ ] junk out there
remember that guy a long time ago out in
new england he just collected tires on
the side of the road for years
and all these [ __ ] tires all over his
property was a [ __ ] mess and he had
like literally farmland and all it was
was tires
everybody was just they had a nickname
and they all thought it was a [ __ ]
bum and all of this [ __ ]
and one day somebody came along and
bought all of them
for like seven figures a little over a
million bucks
that's right he got the last laugh so
that's one for all the hoarders
there's an interesting looking house
look at that thing not quite an
arch oh andrew with your seatbelt
he's just such a rebel when i feel safe
i feel constricted
so i think back in the day probably
humphrey bogart and all those guys used
to go like coyote hunting up here
you know shooting mountain lions and
[ __ ]
it's what you did you thought they were
gonna last look at this guy is that a
viper
dodge viper everybody look at that just
sitting on the street
a [ __ ] 12 cylinder just sitting on
the street daring somebody
to still have to have the [ __ ] cardio
to walk up here and steal it
what the [ __ ] is that what is that
what is that this is like an acting
class how many different ways can you
say it
what is that what is that
that looks like uh the [ __ ] l.a
rivers on the other side of that
i'm gonna go out on a limb say they're
gonna have a leak someday
all right this is [ __ ] mudslide
avenue right here
rain sleet or snow the mailman always
comes out here it's different mudslide
fires or riots he's gonna be bringing
you that [ __ ] gift certificate to win
dixie
jesus christ look at those shady
[ __ ] just sitting there you see
those guys
jesus christ amen is making me know
we're coming up here with cameras
hey maybe we can look down here and see
what the [ __ ] that thing is so i can
finally ask
answer the question of what is that what
is that
no neighbors this guy doesn't have to
have he doesn't have to make a drum room
he could just [ __ ] play his drums
nobody gives a [ __ ]
vacant lot he should buy this thing up
honey i didn't get you a gucci bag this
christmas i bought you a vacant lot
up in the glendale hills
what the [ __ ] is that thing
there's a little [ __ ] steeple down
there this is nice because you got this
valley here so whatever can kill you is
over there
you know look at this guy right up here
all by himself
i gotta be honest with you this is kind
of awesome back here slash a little
scary
this feels like a private drive here no
i guess it isn't
we're going to keep driving until
somebody takes a shot at us
dude how much is this you could take a
running leap under that guy's roof
goddamn kids get off of there [ __ ] up
your place with that three-car garage
gotta love that
i want one you need for my gym
look at that there you go look at that
view right there
that's what you're paying for i thought
that these are going to be giant houses
and they're not they're kind of these
cool
70s style you know when
cereal was all colorful and we used to
eat fluffing other
sandwiches they got these uh look at
these beautiful
uh evergreen dick trees you know it's a
little phallic
guy with the dual jet skis
this uh this is just new money i love
new money someday i make it
i'm gonna get a house on the hill one
jet ski for me
one jet ski for you white cars new money
loves a white car
new money loves a [ __ ] white car look
at them they love white cars
there's something about it more white
car white car
white car they love white cars up here
someday i'm gonna live in those hills
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get me a white
car
i'm gonna get two white jet skis
and the whitest bath towels you've ever
seen i'd buy a buy a lot back there and
build a house
although i'd want to be on the front
side you want the view that backside was
a little too uh anti-government for me
you know what i mean i don't need to be
running into the last mountain lion out
here
as i'm sitting on my porch eating a
[ __ ] bowl of grape nuts like a viagra
commercial
hollywood was named after the guy's wife
her name was hollywoodland hollywood
holly so
the real estate developer named it
hollywood probably after her
holly but her last name wasn't wood was
it red no
unless that was beverly hills though
named after beverly
was she a little hoary you know like
would she suck your dick i don't know
hollywood
sorry
[Laughter]
barnes and noble one of the few left
where you could walk in and buy a book
in and out burger once you get down the
hill after you bought your big house you
get a book
you can go to the movies amc they got an
in and out right here you can fly down
on your squirrel suit get a double
double animal style plenty of places to
park
they got an ikea they got a
zono sushi so no sushi
[Music]
my
you